and they'll take their swings off
another birthday boy spencer watkins
just recently had a birthday a couple
days ago turned 29 years old randy who
had the game-winning two-run homer
yesterday in the eighth inning an
opposite field shot
he shoots this one up the right side
into right field for a base hit brandon
lau on his way to the plate and the
raids just like that break out in front
one nothing you know watkins is throwing
six pitches he's already losing
one-two pitch
strike three call
two down
and joey wendell will step in
wendell up in the fifth spot in the
lineup
joey lifts it into short center field
mullins coming in in a hurry can't get
there that's going to fall in front of
him and a rose arena will score the rays
have their second round of the inning
chris archer this is what he did against
the white sox he came out of that game
had some left hip soreness but he was
cleared and is now back out there to
make this start against the o's now 14
homers 47 rbis on the year for austin
hayes
there's a base hit in the center field
around third ryan mount castle he'll
score
and the orioles are on the board it's
2-1
it's been a good august for action hayes
that's how you answer right back ray's
put up two in the top of the first
orioles have cut the lead in half jordan
luflo leading it off in the second
inning
that's a long one but it's gonna be foul
oh no it hits the pole
that ball hit the top of the foul pole
and he has hit one out to snap that
streak wow how about that you know that
looked off the bad that it wasn't going
to be that close to being fair
and then it was close
and then it was
luplow right off
the foul pole up near the top of the
foul pole
and that is strike three call
bottom of the zone right there with a
fastball
and he gets a chase
it's a one two three second inning
on to the third 3-1 tampa bay
first pitch to mount castle he swings
drive into center field kiermeier back
brett phillips back leaps at the wall
and this one right into the glove of a
fan
ryan mount castle home run number 24 for
the rookie
they cut the lead 3-2 in the third
oh it's another ball ryan mount castle
hits hard right into a glove
happily for him it was not a temp bay
ray glove 389 just cleared the wall over
the grounds through cage
and down he goes
wins applies the tag to complete the
strikeout one down here in the fifth
bounces it down to mount castle he'll
flip
watkins on the bag out number two
pretty efficient now too ben not just
getting outs but getting fairly quick
outs
popped up short left field
austin hayes in under
and another one two three inning so
spencer watkins mowing them down right
now three-two raise
to the raised bullpen first man up is
going to be jt sagua on for the 12th
time
against the yanks jaguar throws got him
swinging breaking ball down and away and
it would have been a strike heading out
swung great pitch by shagwa and there's
one out here in the fifth
two two lifted into the left
rows arena right there for it
orioles with runners at first and third
and two down
and a wave and a miss
and him out in front
stewart strikes out leaving two
we go to the six three two raves
well austin meadows are struck out
looking and then popped to shallow
center two balls two strikes and the
pinch lifted in the air towards right
way up there going back stewart to the
wall gone
two run homer for austin meadows and the
rays have built a 5-2 lead
22nd home run of the season for austin
and he gets over the 90 rbi mark
as well with two more now at 91.
and he got it up over now here's a shot
off the bat of joey wendell and that
baby's gonna go
home run wendell
meadows and wendell go back to back
that's number eight for joey wendell and
on back-to-back pitches the rays have a
three-run inning and a four-run lead
bert's needs some traffic out on the
base paths and maybe a blast trailing by
four
has hit well
way back in left center field
and jorge mateo with a two-run blast
third homer of the year for mateo no
doubt about that one well there is a lot
to like about jorge mateo not just the
speed the glove the arm but boy he can
do this too 104 miles an hour off the
bat 403 feet at travel
suddenly the bases are loaded single and
back to back walks
that's a drive back into deep right all
the way back steward and that is gone
grand slam
off the bat of joey wendell
for wendell his second home run of the
day his ninth home run of the year
and the rays
now have a 10-4 lead
so two on for trey mancini
there's a base hit
into the gap in the left center mullins
will score
mount castle into third and trey
mancini's got an rbi number 64 for him
it's now a 10-5 game
that's what you love about this team i
mean look the wins haven't been there
and it's been a rough season again but
there is never any quit in this team at
all they just keep coming after you
down to first
luplow gets the out there as it skipped
off his glove
a run scores mancini moves to second
announce 10-6 so an rbi
for d.j stewart
and a cut and a miss on the slider
juniors out on strikes
baltimore settles for two
ten sex race
runners take their lead
one two
popped up left side
gutierrez running a long way here comes
hayes he dives and makes the play
my goodness austin hayes
looked like he ran about a mile and made
that sliding catch
[Applause]
he serves this one into center
that ball will drop for a base hit
grazer going to get a run out of that
luplow scores and now another man trying
to score and crossing the plate kermeyer
and into second broncos going to be out
there the rays are going to get a couple
runs out of that before the inning was
finally ended
luke lowe scored kirbyr scored
hit hard
deep right field
way back and cedric mullins has done it
again
two run shot for cedric
number 24 on the year to give him the
team lead
was that the same dad that caught the
home run ball did he catch two of them
cedric mullins towns rail mike ryan
mount castle
you got your 24th and you know what i
got my 24th too
the fly ball lifted into shallow center
kier myers calling and making the catch
the rays win it
it's a 12-8 final
you